Chewie we're home
yes star war fans were home the force
awakens is finally in theaters to take
us back to a galaxy far far away now the
question on your mind be you Jedi or
Sith is most likely will it throw us the
way the original trilogy did we're not
going to do this with spoilers but by
now you know the basics ray Poe and Finn
are our new heroes and they're teaming
up with han and chewbacca and hey
there's a Leia - and did we mention the
lovable droid bb-8 well they're all up
against the new bad guys the first order
which grew out of the defeated Empire
there's Supreme Commander Snoke who's
emperor palpatine ish kylo Ren is Darth
Vader ish and there's a weapon called
the star killer that's kind of deaths
tarnish thankfully the stormtroopers are
still strong troopers but they're not
clones anymore they're humans
there are stunning aerial fights between
x-wings and Thai fighters and falcons
there are lightsaber duels that are part
stealing droids the script by Lawrence
Kasdan and JJ Abrams is chock full of
Star Wars oh ma jizz and inside jokes if
you're a proof fan its it's the
Madeleine cookie of Star Wars movies and
that might actually be its biggest
problem the team cycles through so many
of the themes and tropes from the first
trilogy that at times the force awakens
feels less like an episode 7 and and
more like a remake of episodes 4 through
then again isn't that what we want the
question is whether the movie recaptured
the magic of the originals and the
answer to that thankfully is yes it's a
pitch-perfect distillation of what made
that trilogy so cool Disney and
Lucasfilm are going to keep making these
things forever and if they're all as
good as the force awakens that's going
to be a hell